皆さん酸素
ず分のプレゼントランコムクリスマスの梱包までしてもらったんですよ
dare
買っちゃいましたよ
7000円です何か買う前にいろんな人にに
なんぞや
やめろとか何かお金は無駄とか言われたんですけど
カービィを何だと思ってるんですかファイバいい
歩くだして a
dare
以上ぞウ
4日
ん
目がない
目がないよ開けたらなんとかなりますって多分
ん
スポッ
爪世界です
すー
予定で全2パターン
あではドライバーいうパターン
おっ作さあ
書展示れましたーーーおっまだまだ拙いまだまだまたが未だ山田葉山だね良い
本
うん我々位
うるさーよ細工
ああああああ
空ってなったわねそれでるっていう
なってますよん
まだ悩まないですプルせるぜん
はまずん
んですかっ
動作
おやわけないですか
ん
んえっ
ドア
まずはちょっと触ってみますね
嘘沿った食べて
え
何がすごいかって言ったやっぱ尻尾が付いてるんですが今回ほらか
miyu さんカー
ん
やはりこいつげなんですよめっちゃさん変わりますよ
ウイ t 2
えっ
まずちょっと頭が悪いようですね
版違いますかごめんなさいなんか今 furry 期した
re
eban
ルーラー loop
rar
ん
というわけであの話すとどんどん今こいつはん
その後 love in でカービィがしか話せないんですけど
4日
afo 嘘勝手に倒れるんですか
ってどんどんあの遊んであげるとなんか英語を話せるようになるのでぜひ皆さん
barbie 買ってみてくださいじゃあな
あ暗いとこにしたられるって聞いたんですけど
どうなんですか
いっ